hey everybody I'm Tiffany Smith and we
are here in the Fandango movie clips VIP
lounge at San Diego comic-con with one
of the guys that I'm so excited to be
here let's go
Apollo stereo is amazing so it's
definitely been a long road to getting
this version of Deadpool at comic-con
how does it feel being here with the
fans and actually getting to talk about
it it's crazy cuz a year ago today is
when it was actually the thing that set
it all in motion that was the catalyst
the leak test footage of Deadpool's it's
four year old test footage I know I
still swear his name is Tim Miller as
the director and it galvanized the
Deadpool audience it forced them to
shout yell scream write nasty terrible
letters to Fox executives and here we
are I think that's been really cools
I've been walking around and I've seen
so many Deadpool
yeah so many how does it feel to have
the character embraced by people like
this that's a man me not and you never
get over that that's incredible I mean
you know I've done another superhero
film before as we may know and I know
for a fact that that one didn't actually
have a discernible suit it was a all
computer-generated so just the fact a
dead believer has that it's such a you
know a towel isn't something to connect
to is a really beautiful thing for me I
just I just love that it occupied a
space that no other comic property can
occupy you know it's you have a meta
self-aware fourth wall breaking antihero
and we get to do that in the rated-r
fashion which is just crazy to me it's
crazy that they let us do that I'm
excited about the fourth wall breaking I
know that's a big part of the comics
though but it's actually really hard to
do on film you have to be judicious with
it you can't you know nobody's gonna
want to see a movie where the guys
breaking the fourth wall on every single
scene that's annoying but you know there
are certain moments where you just you
just you have no choice but you just
look straight at him because you're
looking right at the audience remember
the first time I ever did it was in Van
Wilder and it and it's just one moment
in the whole movie but I look straight
down the barrel of the lens and it gets
one of the biggest laughs in the movie
and I think people people appreciate you
what's the dynamic like for the three of
you guys on set because obviously just
sitting here
little bit he clearly earns the name
Merc with a mouth a little bit
what's the dynamic like for you guys
well to them these - yeah we're we are
nuts yeah we broke we broke into a
JCPenney and looted for job oh yeah it
was so fun what was the most trespassing
charge of charges yeah yeah but it was
good cuz tim miller also who i think yep
is also here he's really hard to work
with but he's very open with actors in
terms of you guys riff like do
alternative lines let's get what's on
the script and it's good because the
script was already great so that's a
great foundation to springboard and
hopefully elevate the material and bring
down Ryan Reynolds performance as is and
weasel becomes the superhero and you
know goes off to do more Wolverines it's
a long term planet that's a long game
you